good morning belief nation today's  message is push through over to you  linden drive every part of your body is  gonna say abort like let's get out of  here this is too hard this is painful  abort abort abort this is what your body  will tell you when you start your own  company this is too hard this is not  right I don't have any social life I  don't have any quality of life I'm just  working abort abort  ignore the signals I've pushed through  so the question of the day today is how  do you push through leave it in the  comments below and I'll join the  discussion thank you guys so much for  watching and have an amazing day  continue to believe and I'll see you  again tomorrow morning for another shot  events press